fourth coronavirus relief package facing
a setback on Capitol Hill Senate
Republicans arguing that the first bills
passed should make an impact before
lawmakers move forward with any more
legislation but Democrats disagree I
think immediate aid to Americans is what
is critical and I think that's what the
speaker is focused on there's no
question we have to do more the stimulus
that we have put out is certainly good
but so much of that money is not going
to be received by individuals for weeks
maybe even months joining us now is
Wyoming Senator John Barrasso
he is the chairman of the Senate
Republican Conference and a medical
doctor as well senator good morning and
welcome good to be with you Sandra so do
you believe that a fourth stimulus bill
will be needed well before getting to
that let me first say you know as a
doctor and a senator I want to make sure
that people are taken care of in terms
of their health and their well-being and
this is going to be a critical and
crucial week in America so the more
people can do to to stay at home to wash
their hands frequently to avoid touching
their face the better it's going to be
with regard to a fourth language I did
talk the president as well as Senator
McConnell this week first we have to
make sure that this last bill that cares
Act actually works to get relief to the
people that need it which is just about
everybody in America to make sure that
the health care providers get what they
need and to make sure that our small
businesses are able to get these loans
we put out about 17,000 loans already
about five billion dollars but there's
350 billion dollars in this project with
regard to a fourth package I believe
that there will be one but I have to
tell you Sandra there is just no way
that Nancy Pelosi can once again bring
to that her list of liberal leftist
approaches of the the green New Deal and
election reform think she's talking
about about diversity of corporate ports
this is a crisis that our country is
facing anything in this forth package
has to make sure that we have fulfilled
the needs that we promised would be met
through the third pack
so it sounds like you agree with Mitch
McConnell in this wait-and-see approach
with the first three rounds of stimulus
that was overwhelmingly bipartisan so
how do you keep the approach to relief
for Americans bipartisan when clearly
Nancy Pelosi is making the case for more
stimulus and Mitch McConnell's saying
hold on let's wait and see well we
actually had that process in a very
bipartisan way in the Senate before
Nancy Pelosi came in with this big
liberal wish list and now she's trying
it again with phase four where she wants
tax breaks as she said for millionaires
in the in the in the blue states well
that's not going to cut it either if we
do get to a phase four and you want to
actually we're at a point where we're
beyond this and we have the disease
behind us and we need to stimulate the
economy one of the things we've been
talking about is the highway bill the
infrastructure bill things we need to do
to help rebuild the country I've talked
with the president about that we have a
bill that's come out of the committee in
the Senate that I chair it's passed 21
to nothing every Republican every
Democrat has voted for we ought to stick
with the bipartisan things that work
rather than the sort of things that that
Nancy Pelosi is trying to bring to the
table to take the country in a direction
that the American people say let's deal
with the crisis that are is affecting us
right now
well senator you do come at this from
such a unique perspective also being a
medical doctor as well as a u.s. senator
doctor Falchi over the weekend was
warning against the dangers of those
states who have not implemented complete
stay at home orders Wyoming is one of
them here's doctor foul gee the tension
between federally mandated versus states
rights to do what they want is something
I don't want to get into but if you look
at what's going on in this country I
just don't understand why we're not
doing that we really should be so is
that something that should be considered
for your state well you can always
depend on the people of Wyoming to do
the right thing we do have a state of
emergency in Wyoming anyone coming into
our state there's a 14 day quarantine
people are staying at home but remember
that people are spread out here we only
have about five people per square mile
we have been
socially distancing the entire hundred
and thirty years that we've been a state
we survived by people helping people
neighbor helping neighbor right now we
have 200 cases no deaths and we hope to
keep it that way by doing continuing to
do the right thing what's the risk or
the harm in issuing that stay at home
order statewide well people are staying
at home in Wyoming so it's being done
already I think the governor has struck
the right balance and this is the people
of Wyoming know what's best in Wyoming
we're going to continue to do that we're
going to continue to follow all the
recommendations that are there in
Wyoming people are really staying home I
mean if you go to the grocery store
people are wearing masks keeping
distances they're special hours set up
for seniors but it is a state where
neighbors help neighbors we're going to
continue to do it that way that sign of
unity is something that we can all come
to appreciate during this difficult time
for our country senator really
appreciate you coming on the program
this morning great to see you Thank You
Sandra